so not a lot of people are probably
familiar with the phrase twice
exceptional and in a school system it's
a it's a diagnosis to describe kids who
simultaneously have a specific learning
disability whether it's a reading
difficulty dyslexia ADHD any one of the
learning disabilities you can be
diagnosed diagnosed for few time
simultaneously have a specific learning
disability and you're intellectually
gifted in to actually or creatively
gifted we have this false dichotomy that
we've set up in the school system
between learning disabled and gifted
that if you're have if you're in special
education for instance that it's kind of
hard for us to see how you could also be
gifted or you could also be
extraordinarily intelligent
extraordinary creative and this way this
label of twice exceptional was created
to recognize that there are so many
people who have been diagnosed with a
learning disability but that is not the
totality of who they are that is not
define all they are who they are both
are strengths all of us have strengths
and weaknesses and a lot of people who
have learning disabilities it masks
their it can mask their strengths but
their strengths are still there and we
can still get at it in other ways
through projects through through just
recognizing that they are not defined by
their learning disability and there's a
lot of researchers psychologists and
clinicians that are starting to figure
out new ways of finding the intelligence
in people that as tend to fall by the
wayside and there's new methodologies
and new techniques that were using to
discover the giftedness that lies in in
lots of students there's been an over
alliance on looking at the global IQ
score to to assess those intelligence so
like you someone take an IQ test and you
average together their performance on
the entire test well it shows that
students are twice exceptional our
students who have learning disabilities
that's not the good reflection of their
true intelligence just averaging
together their performance on a testing
session because their learning
disability can mask and pull down
certain areas but they could still show
extraordinary high areas in other ways
that and that gets lost when you average
it all together so there are new
methodologies that are that are be
created that are that we're using to not
just measure Solon's intelligence or
creativity just through a testing
session we are first of all we're using
IQ IQ tests to look at specific
abilities and patterns of strengths and
weaknesses so not looking at that global
or total IQ score we're also going
beyond the IQ test and we're getting
teacher ratings you know the more you
can triangulate lots of different
information from lots of different
sources you get a much better reflection
of Seoul's intelligence and creativity
and get to parent parent ratings you ask
parents what's a child like at home you
know is the child really curious is the
child
constant asking questions ask teachers
is that is the child seem like they're
bored with the material that you're
teaching are they ready for more
intellectual challenges do they seem to
question assumptions a lot a lot of the
indicators of creativity there's all
there are lots of other characteristics
we can be on the lookout for for
intellectual and creative creative gift
nasai go beyond IQ type competencies
things like deep sensitivity deep you
know deep caring about the world and
about the suffering of others it doesn't
even have to just be in the academic
domain
I think we just need to keep our eyes
open to as many indicators potential
indicators of intelligence and
creativity that is all around us and so
we can really make sure that we we limit
the amount of students to fall between
the cracks